[Music]
she helped tony get his mojo back
helped bruce reconnect with his humanity
helped cap find his true
purpose and helped hawkeye uh
keep being hawkeye baby you want to go
talk to him okay
go grab your hammer and you go fly you
talk to him
but now natasha finally gets to tell her
own story
about the time she helped her own
replacement join the mcu
black widow you've been waiting to see
the mcu's first female superhero get her
own movie
and waiting and waiting and
waiting but natasha romanov is finally
getting the mid-tier solo marvel movie
she deserves because the ultimate sign
of respect in pop culture
is getting your chance to keep important
object x out of the hands of military
leader y
by taking down massive airship z i know
marvel's taking some risks here and
there but this one definitely sticks to
the old plan
so this was the big plan huh i like your
plan
except it sucks so let me do the plan we
need a plan of attack
i have a plan attack first of all you're
copying me from when i said i had a plan
what about our plan
american bachelors in europe that's your
plan that's a solo plan come on this is
my plan
my plan was to drive us away it's the
plan
get to know the real natasha romanoff a
woman struggling to overcome the trauma
of being a child actor i remember this
day
we shot christmas thanksgiving easter
and summer vacation all on monday
she's got nothing but her wits and flips
to protect her in a dangerous world of
super spies
although at some point she entered the
cheat code that turns off environmental
damage
what and for one scene she turns into
mega man but they never mention it again
what journey to russia where everyone
speaks with their best
uh let's call it sokovian accent or just
doesn't even try
i was the family reunion unless you're
actually from eastern europe
in which case you are mute and me the
surrogate family who raised black widow
back in her 90s ghost world phase
there's red guardian david harbor's
latest attempt to hide in a siberian
prison
until everyone forgets about the hellboy
remake molina
a monster war criminal who tortures pigs
and played a willing active role in
kidnapping little girls and brainwashing
them into fembots
but she regrets it so no harm no foul
mama take care of yourself okay
don't worry i got this and elena the
mischievous
little braided hair sister from little
women who's now the mischievous little
braided hair sister
who's murdered untold hundreds of people
i'm not the killer that little girls
call their hero
i don't know elena say three cute things
about your vest and i'll take a whole
russian prison's worth of dead bodies
off your ledger it has a lot of pockets
but i use them all the time and i made
some of my own modifications i know how
much you like it
does have a lot of pockets very handy
pockets yeah it's so cool right
it's good yes and you can put so much
stuff in there
you wouldn't even know oh she likes the
vest so cute
this would be a cool way to die i'm sure
they deserved it
thrill at a story that dares to ask what
if the most powerful force on earth
girl power fell into the wrong hands
as the evil mastermind harvey weinstein
i mean drake off
builds a floating fortress that evades
detection because
it's cloudy and uses the power of his
colossal stank to keep him
safe prevents you from committing
violence against me
he's infiltrated the halls of power with
a sister soldier hood of mind-controlled
assassins
and doing his evil bidding is the
taskmaster a martial artist with the
ability to mimic any hero's moves
but none of their personality or
charisma
because now that marvel has themselves a
deadpool someone had to become the
deadpool from wolverine origins
so if you're looking for a lefem nikita
but a lot
or what if charlie's angels but evil or
what if propaganda was used to twist
trafficked young girls towards the
nefarious purposes of the rich and
powerful
including bill clinton and condoleezza
rice but like could also be a ride at
disneyland
then strap in for a movie that's good at
being pretty much everything
except a black widow solo film
starring sister traitor soldier spy
florence and the regime super borat
the manservant's tale oh a y spy eh
babe pig in the study boy bruv they call
me dry golfing
the hurt stalker the winter sold her
minnie jovovich venice the menace
and the most brutal murder in black
widow's history
you've always been a really good friend
to me
in soviet russia m sees you
wow i wonder which full-grown adult
managed to lose a tic-tac-toe
hawkeye definitely hall guy feel like
you don't know that much about natasha
romanoff after watching her movie
we asked a real psychiatrist to tell us
what's her whole
you know deal click the thumbnail on the
right for a real analysis
of black widow's psychological profile i
only enjoy
craft macaroni and cheese ice cream
stupid sexy flanders